tanto biden como Trump ya están
calificando lo que está ocurriendo como
una vergüenza Por qué existe Esta
división entre los republicanos
esto muestra lo que es o crisis que han
creado desde hay dos cosas la
polinización y también la populismo que
ha empezado más que nada con Trump para
los dos lados es un espectáculo para los
demócratas están trayendo palomitas para
verlo mientras que los republicanos
están sufriendo lo pero es un crisis que
ahora no tiene salida y
estamos esperando a ver cómo ellos
pueden llegar a un acuerdo pero muy
difícil hacer llegar al acuerdo cuando
hay tanta polarización bueno sabemos que
el bloqueo viene del llamado freedom
cocus Quiénes son y qué es lo que
Proponen ellos
bueno ellos son los los 20 personas de
los publicanos que son aún más de la
derecha que los otros pero todos más o
menos están de acuerdo con lo que
quieren hacer es que ellos no les gusta
la persona que está propuesta para ser
el líder de los publicanos Entonces es
más de la persona que sus que sus
políticas Entonces ellos El problema es
que ellos no quieren comprometerse ellos
han dicho que no van a aceptar las
personas y en la democracia hay que
comprometer porque no se puede tener que
ganar siempre no una democracia requiere
que los dos lados llegan al cuero se
excepto que mira yo estoy ganando este
vez y tú la próxima vez pero ellos no
pueden decirlo a sus votantes lo que han
dicho que no somos Estamos elegidos para
hacer una cosa es rechazar a esa persona
y es muy difícil hacerlo ahora
bueno son dos días de votaciones Pero
esto se puede extender las votaciones
que sea hasta que sea elegido el
presidente de la cámara Qué impacto
tiene este retraso en los temas sobre
los que va a legislar el congreso
es muy difícil porque hasta los nuevos
congresistas no pueden ser jurados para
ser formalmente miembros del Congreso
entonces este todo este proceso es algo
que pasa antes de que sean
entrados por la mente en el congreso
Entonces no pueden hacer ni una cosa más
hasta elegir
Entonces
vamos a ver si pueden encontrar una
manera de salir entonces están hablando
de varias oportunidades puede ser que
una persona que ahora no sea un
congresista que puede ser líder Pero
ahora ni uno de los dos lados pueden no
pueden hablar entre sí para llegar a un
acuerdo entonces todo congreso no está
funcionando a un congreso normalmente
bueno en este momento está muy
cuestionado el apoyo del expresidente
Donald Trump y se lo está ofreciendo a
mccarthy esto de alguna manera lo está
favoreciendo o lo perjudica
n Con quién estás hablando porque de un
lado
influencia pero en este momento con
muchos las congresistas están diciendo
que no no nos importa que no estamos
apoyando
y no y no estamos con Trump para el otro
lado tampoco entonces en parte yo es una
sorpresa que él está tratando de mover a
los diputados pero
sin el éxito sí no ha tenido éxito